I'm Harry fagle I'm a poet for 25 years
I serve Las Vegas as a captain with the
Las Vegas Metropolitan Police Department
I'm retired now in just a pulley the
arena smokes in the dawn light phones
ring and ring and no one answers
swirling ghosts floats such silent
dancers the scene starts as a horror
show a solemn blight so the night at the
Route 91 right the night it happened I
was working as a commander in Laughlin
and I was at home and my one of my guys
called me and said that there was a
shooting going on murder happened and
the world holds its breath whatever was
the meaning of such atrocity this has
been a more peaceful City now permeated
by the reek of death I immediately left
my wife crying at home and went to the
scene where I ended up at the command
post now five years later five years has
gone by and I hope that they're healing
I know I've healed from it a little bit
but I know a lot of people are suffering
terribly so when
the news came to me the news folks and
asked me to write something positive
about the route about this incident I
felt like it was a big challenge but I
understood the need for it get light
still Shines on the high plain sparrows
fly from everywhere and anywhere gently
lifting the Dead with a miserable care
restoring sanity to the insane as the
souls Ascend Skyward and leave the cold
ground we all found a way to come
together in peace put aside our
different lives and drop the collective
lease create Community healing so deep
and profound a lot of people save lives
that night how do I capture all of the
good that came from something so awful I
watch mothers and fathers sisters and
brothers Gathering food and drinking
great baskets delivered with care of the
First Responders who never ever asked it
almost everyone caring less for
themselves more for others such as the
gift of humanity in the midst of such
Calamity when the center was peeled for
me and I was able to turn to my
community and find truth and goodness
and the removal of stains of blood I was
able to receive in the middle of pain
without Fanfare or ruthless refrain a
gift from the universe of the truth from
above we are Vegas we are Vegas strong
we are love